striking a pose in jeans and a
sweatshirt with a shorter haircut and
his puppy by his side elliott tells time
i'm fully who i am the 34 year old actor
opens up in a candid interview detailing
what it's been like coming out as a
transgender man since publicly sharing
the news
on instagram in december what it was
anticipating was a lot of support
and love and a massive amount of hatred
and transphobia
that's essentially what happened he also
opens up about his struggle with
depression
anxiety and panic attacks saying i just
never recognized myself
for a long time i could not even look at
a photo of myself
elliot further explains that even though
he's an actor having to just put on a
t-shirt cut for a woman
to play a female role would make him so
unwell
he also reveals that he had top surgery
last year to remove his breast tissue
right before coming out
and that now he feels more comfortable
in his own body saying
it has completely transformed my life
not only life-changing but life-saving
elliot also talks about his childhood
and how he always wanted to cut his hair
short
i wanted to be a boy i would ask my mom
if i could be someday
and thanks to the global lockdown his
dream came true as he admits that's what
led him to come to terms with his gender
identity
i had a lot of time on my own to really
focus on things that i think in so many
ways
unconsciously i was avoiding i was
finally able to
embrace being transgender and letting
myself fully become who i
am one topic elliott didn't dive into is
his divorce from emma porter
apart from saying they've remained close
friends but when it comes to his acting
career he says
i'm really excited to act now that i'm
fully who i am
in this body no matter the challenges
and difficult moments of this
nothing amounts to getting to feel how i
feel now